[Musique]
année de la pandémie et de la mise sur
pause de l'économie certains croyaient
que 2020 qui serait une année marquante
en ce qui a trait à la préservation de
la biodiversité
et le dernier rapport du fonds mondial
pour la nature nous dit pas si vite
en cinquante ans de 1970 à 2000 16 68%
des espèces sauvages sont tombés en
situation de déclin le message ne passe
pas donc on continue à voir déclin qui
est extrêmement important et quand les
espèces ne vont pas bien la nature les
écosystèmes c'est un signe ça me dit
neutre environnement au canada près de
six espèces sur dix déjà en pire ils
risquent de disparaître
parmi celles ci figure le caribou le
rorqual à bosse dont les populations ou
diminué dernièrement et la baleine noire
la baleine noire évidemment c'est une
espèce qui est vraiment en voie de
disparition au point où si la tendance
se maintient puis si les conditions
restent comme elles le sont actuellement
il lui reste environ une vingtaine
d'années étant donnée la dynamique de
ces populations le taux de naissances
ecce terra l'humain avec ses modes de
production extensif est le principal
responsable de cette détérioration
cela dit il est encore possible de
renverser la tendance selon le fonds
mondial pour la nature avec entre autres
l'augmentation des aires protégées
la transformation de notre modèle
agricole et la réduction de notre
consommation de protéines animales ici
gabriel proulx rage au canada montréal